The Joe Rogan experience,
it's a matter of time,
right?
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Well my dad is hilarious.
My Dad is 86 and three quarters and he
sent me an email today and it said,
here's a link to an article about a
marijuana reform,
and he said,
oh,
it's going to be legal in my lifetime.
I was like,
Dad.
I said,
I hope you're right.
You know,
even if you have to live another 20
years.
So I would have never thought in 2013.
It was still be illegal.
When I was a kid I,
I thought it was a matter of time.
Well I was on the board of normal for
awhile,
quite awhile and I was with people who
started normal in 1970 and 71 and
thought it would be legal in a few
years.
So that sort of tempers my,
a sense of time to be with people who,
you know,
over 40 years ago thought it was only
going to be a few years away that
marijuana will be legal.
Unfortunately they're still working to
try to help bring that about.
Do you lose enthusiasm sometimes when
you see that it's still illegal after
all this,
now it's the,
um,
it's about,
it's a worthy,
like on a worthy opponent.
It's a worthy goal and so I think we
just do what we want to do.
There's times when I felt like I was so
blocked that I needed to do something
where I could actually see change and so
I stopped work for a week and painted my
house.
Great.
That's really must,
must,
must get to feel like you're spinning
your wheels sometimes.
Well,
for years,
and we just spent four years with Health
Canada trying to get an import export
permit to bring in eight grams of Mgma
and this is after Health Canada had
approved the protocol and our irb had
approved the protocol and the four years
it took and they went through all these
ridiculous things about the pharmacy had
to have bulletproof glass.
It had to have all these alarm systems.
Class people are gonna come in and steal
your eight grams of acid.
That was eight grams.
Yeah.
That would be in a safe and the safe had
to be disguised in a wooden cabinet and
the had to be bolted to the floor.
They were harder than the U.
S it was ridiculous,
but.
But we eventually prevailed.
We just took every ridiculous thing and
we did it.
I mean,
my policy is surrender when there's
certain kinds of irrational things
coming from people who are more
powerful,
try to give it to them.
Well,
that's probably why you're in the
position that you're in your facilitator
of this.
I'm willing to dialogue venture forth.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then there's the legislation that is
being passed right now in several states
to start to try to stop,
to prohibit with these guys are doing my
filming under cover,
so it's.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
How has,
how,
how's that flying?
How are they allowing people to do that?
Because everyone is outraged when they
see those videos.
Even the media,
they watched those videos of people.
Like I saw one of this abuse that was
going on with these cows were the sky
was like hitting a cow with a crowbar
and it's there.
So horrific.
And again,
another thing is being exposed by
technology.
I believe that that video could
have very well come from the guy that we
feature.
Um,
he's sort of the main one of the biggest
undercover animal rights activist and
blur out his face or his voice.
But we definitely heard his.
Actually he has,
he's had,
I don't know how many name changes
throughout his life and this,
he's been doing it for 10 years and he's
sort of a few ever want to do any
undercover filming.
This is the guy who needs to talk to
him.
And he actually gave me some training
because a lot of all of this show is
about undercover filming.
He gave me some training into filming
undercover.
He sent me out into the parking lot and
told me that first I had to go to that
woman over there.
She's a perfect stranger and you have to
ask her.
You have to get information from her.
I want to know where she lived before
she lived here and I had to go and do
that and I passed that really easily,
but then the second test that he made me
do was I had to go out there and make a
woman sort of run away from me because
she was scared and I'm not very good at
that.
I'm good at getting information from
people,
but I can't.
It's not in my nature to be mean or
scary or intimidating.
And so I went to a parking lot and I
just started acting wild,
crazy and not really scary.
Just crazy.
Like where is water?
Where can I find some water?
People were just staring at me with this
crazy woman probably thinking that was
on bath salts.
Are they trying to get you to do all
this?
So this is part of the training is that
you have to be able to make people feel
either very comfortable with you so they
give you information that you need,
that you want to get for your,
for your undercover filming or very
uncomfortable with you so that you feel
the need to either leave.
So you can fill more or intimidating to
a point,
intimidated to the point that you will
release any information you give without
actually resorting to violence
obviously.
So it was really,
it was really an interesting little
practice that we had with them.
It's an amazing how much people identify
with their genitals because there's a
thing that women hate more than not want
more than anything was left.
I mean that's a massive generalization
that has taught myself.
But there's one thing that a lot of
women really do not appreciate.
And that's stinky pussy jokes.
You know,
you could talk about your stinky feet,
who can talk about a girl.
Stinky feet,
can talk about a girl's breath.
You can talk about our girls,
but you can't talk about a girl stinky
pussy to them.
You can lose a lot of people that don't
like when you talk about it.
Even onstage,
really like,
yes,
yes.
I've seen someone do a stinky pussy joke
and I've seen women in the audience
going,
oh,
come on.
Just upset that you put that possibility
out there.
I've never smelled a bed fucking pussy
like
coke.
No,
I'm a fucking gets that.
If I pick up a chick at a bar,
she's drugged.
I'm thinking,
I'm like that thick.
Take a shower.
I just won't help us.
But I got my finger banged that girl and
I'm in Idaho falls.
And then being an American Indian I
finger,
she had those daisy dukes was triple
night is and I'm all warmed up.
I got like $32.
I got no blow.
I'm drinking budweiser fucking furious
and I'm dancing on it and she's letting
me touch her Joe Rogan and I stick my
hand in like this way,
like full finger,
lose my fucking Twat.
And I had that fucking yoga look at size
and I was bringing her this way,
you know a Bruce Lee,
you know,
I was
like Mikey and I took it out.
I could.
I was dancing with it.
I could smell my hand and that was it.
I've met by just go do something
and you can't get it off.
Do you know that the smell of fish is
actually from old come usually.
So if it's a really strong fish smelled,
that means there's common side of her.
That's funny because that's what my
ball's always smelled like if I jerk off
and don't wipe up.
Smells like fish.
So realizing I used to take ladies about
my own jazz.
I shoot,
she did my pubes and pull my underwear.
I buy away.
I've done that dozens of times in my
life to shoot of.
I jerk off,
I just shoot a load on my pubes.
I don't even bother cleaning now,
but I just pull my underwear up.
I do that.
I'm in the house.
I'm like,
as long as it's covered,
whatever we give a fuck.
If I'm in the whole town by myself,
I'll get who cares on the bed and laid
on it.
I don't give a fuck fuck fucking all
day.
It's.
I thought about it.
This is my little tropical helmet juice.
But
you're a fucking human being.